hi I'm Ryan her and this talk is about
Picasso and programming in 1945 Picasso
created a series of bulls where he
started with a fairly realistic bull
like you see on the left and through a
gradual progressive process he
deconstructed the bull abstracting it to
its essence to a simplified geometric
form so in 1945 Picasso did that in 2010
an anonymous illustrator posted a meme
on tumblr and reddit how to draw an owl
again we see a transition between two
states step one draw some circles step
two draw the rest of the owl so the
interesting thing when we compare these
two sets of images well they're moving
in opposite directions right the the owl
is moving from simple to detailed but
the bull Picasso's Bulls actually moved
in the opposite direction
it went from more complex more detailed
to simplified and that's often what we
want to do in software right we want to
we want to really simplify our software
overtime to reduce the complexity to
find the right abstractions so much as
Picasso was seeking the right
abstraction for the essence of the bull
software developers and mathematicians
are often seeking the right abstraction
that are concise and elegant and
simplified and it's not easy regardless
of which direction we want to go right
the meme is about the difficulty from
from going too simple to the detail if
you don't see all the step by step
process in between and it may be even
more difficult to remove complexity like
Picasso did so regardless of which
direction we want to go how do we learn
to do it sometimes we can feel stuck so
I'm wondering here if we abstract
Picasso's process of abstraction could
that help us get unstuck could we learn
from him well even Picasso got stuck
sometimes
a few months before Picasso drew his
bulls he was stuck on a particular
painting for weeks he was making another
World War two type of painting it was a
follow up to his famous Guernica shown
here this one was called charnel-house
and he was stuck on it you can see up in
the top left some faint pencil lines
well really threw out some faint pencil
lines and especially in that top left
it's not all colored in so he felt stuck
and a friend asked him what's going on
and Picasso said I'm going very slowly
because I don't want to ruin it I don't
want to ruin the initial freshness of my
work have you ever felt like that
whether you're working on software or
something else you're worried because
you don't want to ruin it and you're not
sure how to move forward well Picasso
continued explaining to his friend he
said if it were possible there would
never be a finished canvas if it were
possible I would leave it as it is while
I began over and carried it to a more
advanced state on another canvas there
would never be a finished canvas but
just the different states of a single
painting which normally disappear in the
course of work so Picasso was struggling
with this if only it were possible well
it turns out that it is possible in
another medium and Picasso used a
different medium for his bowls and he
didn't do just two he did 11 balls and
he used the medium of printmaking
because each medium has different
possibilities sometimes called
affordances and in printmaking one of
the possibilities is the ability to make
copies much more easily but Picasso was
actually exploring a specific type of
printmaking which was new to him at the
time lithography because lithography
enabled not just copies but also changes
because prior forms of printmaking like
itching and metal plates you can make
many copies but you can imagine that
itching in a metal plate that's pretty
permanent right and similarly with
carving into a wood block for woodblock
prints but lithography
you use an oily cran on a limestone and
wherever that cran was then the ink
transfers it attaches to that and it is
possible to make changes it's actually
not necessarily as easy as you might
think but Picasso experimented with it
and it was possible to make changes and
so this medium enabled him to to work in
these progressive states and to save the
changes along the way so that we could
see that step-by-step process his
creative process his process of
abstraction he worked in the studio of a
man in France named Merlot and Merlot
and the other studio workers they they
gave quotes about their memories of
Picasso working on this process
Merlot said one day Picasso started work
on the famous bull it was a superb
well-rounded bull I thought myself that
that was that but not at all a second
state and a third still well-rounded
followed and so it went on but the bull
was no longer the same it began to get
smaller to lose weight Picasso was
taking away rather than adding to his
composition he was carving away slices
of his bowl at the same time and after
each change
we pulled a proof he could see that we
were puzzled he made a joke but went on
working and then he produced another
bowl and each time less and less of the
bull remained he used to look at me and
laugh look he would say we ought to give
this bit to the butcher
the housewife could say I want that
piece or this one in the end the Bulls
head was like that of an ant and the
last proof that remained only a few
lines I'd watched him work reducing
always reducing I still remember the
first bowl I said to myself what I don't
understand is that he had ended up where
maybe he should have started but Picasso
was seeking his own bull and to achieve
his one-line bull he had gone in
successive stages through all the other
Bulls and when you look at that line you
cannot imagine how much work it involved
so that was what Merlot said about it
here's what Picasso said about it he
said a picture used to be a sum of
editions
my case a picture is a sum of
destructions I do a picture then I
destroy it and it would be very
interesting to preserve these mortar
metamorphoses of a picture possibly one
might then discover the path followed by
the brain in materializing a dream so
what I thought about this captivating
quote I had some questions one you know
is it true that there were more
destructions than additions or how can
we how can we quantify that how can we
get a better understanding of that
because really how does it work how does
this process work and so I had this idea
of how we could use another medium to to
explore these changes between states not
just the 11 states but the differences
in between each one and so I thought
that I would do what could be analogous
to a get DIF to have a color-coded
representation of the changes between
states so here we see the tenth and
eleventh state and then on the right we
see the black lines are the portions
that were unchanged red are the portions
that were removed in the transition
between states and green are the lines
that were added and I didn't use the
medium of computation first to do this I
actually used the medium of tracing
paper I simply print it out as a proof
of concept printed out these these
states here and then and then traced
over them and it really was even this
process of embodied thinking right you
know thinking thinking with your hand
and following the same path that Picasso
followed obviously when he's talking
about the path followed by the brain in
realizing a dream that's a more
metaphorical path but I thought if I if
I follow his literal path of his hand
maybe I would start to absorb that
understanding and so this was a great
way to prototype this medium was was the
most accessible fastest way for me to
prototype but it would have been rather
tedious to do this for all the states
and so
I figured out how to do it
computationally to outsource that work
to to my computer so I'll show a demo in
in Jupiter notebook and I actually think
because of the difficulty of switching
screens which I apologize for I will
save that for the end and go through my
slides so here are the diffs between all
11 states so now there's not 11 images
there's 10 because there are there are
10 transitions in between the 11 images
and you can see by looking through these
images that picasso's process at first
was additive we see more green in this
transition between state 1 & 2 where the
bull bulks up and becomes monstrous and
form but then we see in the red exactly
like Paquette Picasso used this metaphor
of the butcher carving up pieces we see
him with these with this vast swaths of
red carving up the bowl and continuing
to reduce it and subtract and delete
parts of the bowl until we were left
with this very simplified schematic
linear representation in the final
transition so I got really excited
working with the tracing paper working
with with code to calculate the
differences between these images but I
wondered if I could go further I came
back to this idea about discovering the
path followed by the brain and
materializing a dream and I thought
about some work that Brett Victor did
where again he traces a path literally
in his talk about inventing on principle
and he shows the example of a platformer
game like Mario and and Brett Victor
says if you have a process in time and
you want to see changes immediately
you have to map time to space and so he
puts all the changes in this onion skin
sort of view that is a lot more than
just eleven states right to see the
fluid motion by mapping time to space to
really see
the path that the mario like character
takes in the platformer game and so I
wondered if I could use the
computational medium or as brett victor
calls it the dynamic medium with magic
ink to go even further an understanding
Picasso's process of abstraction and
just as understanding his process might
help us to make software making software
could help us to understand Picasso so I
actually came up with this animated
representation between states 9 10 and
11 that is looping through here and I
took some artistic license because some
of Picasso's decisions are lost to time
there they're not encoded in the in the
intermediate States to say what order
did he make these changes in right but
if I were to segment it out and make
these changes line by line then I can
get a simulation of what it might have
been like to sit shoulder by shoulder
with Picasso and see him making these
artistic decisions these choices how to
simplify the bull through the last two
states let me walk walk you through it
line by line so he starts out by saying
this complicated face that he's left
with over here let me get rid of almost
all of that I can just use this sort of
leaf oval type of shape but get rid of
the horns and all the complexity in the
face and then I'll draw in some newer
simpler horns and just a single small
line for the neck now I want to this
this front leg it looks kind of funky
there there's a whole lot of structure
there and I can reduce that front leg to
a single line and you know what with the
other front leg I can do that as well I
don't need two lines I can use a single
line and now I have my two front legs
even simpler and then now this whole
complicated mess in the back where we
have the tail in many lines for for the
hind legs I can remove almost all of
that and this one curved Picasso
keeps this one curved but he repurposes
it he's playing games he's exploring
puzzles with it previously that curve
was part of the hind leg now he must
have this idea that that could instead
be repurposed as the tail if he simply
draw a little connecting line and
further on now this this bowl has
already gotten simple but how could he
make it even more elegant and compressed
for the final state well he starts out
by by choosing to get rid of all the
complexity in the in really in the body
that polygons so remove all those
interior lines and also this this
diagonal line that is the the underside
of the bowl it gets a little bit
complicated there where it joins those
two legs you can redraw that line and
make it simpler and they all connect at
a single point there then he actually
changes his mind about the tail said
that what he did before was a way to
simplify it but he's actually able to
simplify it even further and instead
reuse part of that curve of the the hind
of the animal and simply extend it down
and then that becomes the tail but it
actually connects up to the same point
that it was before so he's playing these
games of what are the different ways
that I can connect the dots sometimes
people use the metaphor of cave
paintings how ancient humanity had this
compulsion to to draw images on the
walls of caves well I also think that
you could make a metaphor to ancient
humanity's practice of looking up at the
stars and seeing all the different
images that you could make in the Stars
and different cultures found different
ways to connect the Stars into
constellations there are so many
possibilities Picasso is exploring those
possibilities here he further then he he
removed he moves and simplifies the
genitals there and completes that curve
there now he is saying you know I
simplified the head a lot but I can make
it even
and simpler I can do that the the head
of an ant like Merlot called it just a
simple single circle almost a dot and
these horns which if you saw the 11th
state and you didn't have this context
you might think why are these horns a
funny shape why does that why does that
one go so much farther up than the other
again it's like the like the
constellation playing these games with
these puzzles of how do you connect the
dots
he's reusing the same dots that he was
before but the one horn goes up to the
same point and the other one goes to the
base of where the horns were before and
finally now that he simplified the head
one final step this this complex polygon
in the front he can he can remove that
and make two lines that all come to to a
single point so this is how we can
simulate Picasso's creative process even
though we take some liberties here we
extrapolate these are almost certainly
wrong in the details we don't know which
order Picasso made his marks to add and
subtract but yet we were able to see
possibilities that we weren't able to
see before
so each medium has strengths and
weaknesses each representation has
strengths and weaknesses for example to
see changes at a glance we could use a
different type of diff where instead of
using all the pixels in the image like
on the left which this is this to me is
a beautiful fascinating image to look at
but it's awfully complex it's hard to
see what's going on instead on the right
we could use a more geometric
representation where we're using shapes
instead of pixels the silhouettes of
those states of the bowl or you could
call them concave holes if you'd like so
this representation while we lose some
details in what's going on in the bowl
and that could be a perceived
disadvantage the advantage is that this
way of abstracting Picasso's abstraction
process we're able to gain some clarity
and how that shape
change so you make these trade-offs I'd
like to to show another geometric
representation and again I will show the
jupiter notebook at the very end and the
representation is what you see here at
the very top of this triangle so I'm
going to come back and explain this but
this this image that's at the top of the
triangle that was generated with code
with Python code to say take the tenth
state and then apply a line
simplification algorithm to that tenth
state called the Douglas puker algorithm
which removes points from the lines to
simplify those lines and by applying
this mathematical algorithm the Douglas
puker lines simplification algorithm
could we try to in some way move from
the tenth state to something that
approximates the eleventh state now this
this is wrong that top that top image is
not what the 11th state looks like it
could be interesting it's but it's it's
it's different so it's not it's not an
accurate representation of that 11th
state but it's interesting to see why
it's wrong and to do that I'm using here
Scott McCloud's triangle of abstraction
from his book understanding comics so he
says you can you can make a triangle
that maps out the possibilities of
visual abstraction we're in the lower
left corner you start with resemblance
like this photo of the girl and as you
progress up along that axis then you
have pure abstraction picture plane
abstraction where you're deconstructing
into geometric forms that lose the
resemblance to the original image and
also even lose the semantic meaning it's
no longer a face
it's just lines and shapes and colors
and polygons then there's another type
of abstraction which is along the bottom
axis that moves from resemblance to
meaning this is iconic abstraction and
like you see the face getting more
cartoony where a single circle and two
dots and a line can represent a face but
that is iconic abstraction it still is
the meaning of the face it's
representing that and the challenge here
if we if we map various renditions of
the Bulls onto Scott McCloud's triangle
of abstraction we see that okay we'll
start with resemblance with this first
state of the bull now this this is still
abstracted it's still as some evocative
lines but it's the most realistic it has
the most resemblance so we'll start
there if we move up towards picture
plane abstraction that's the Douglass
puker algorithm that could be
represented representative a pure
abstraction if we move along the bottom
towards iconic abstraction that that
preserves the meaning but loses the
resemblance then the way to represent
this form of abstraction could be taking
a hand-drawn picture of a bull by an
untrained person not an artist from
Google's quick draw datasets where
Google collected tens of thousands of
drawings of different animals and
different everyday objects a crowdsource
this data set so that they could use it
to train recurrent neural networks to
generate new images but again that type
of extraction is a different time type
and the trouble the difficulty with
trying to capture Picasso style with his
unique flavor of abstraction is that he
is not really doing one or the other
he's splitting the difference he's going
his own way his own path and
incorporating elements of both picture
plane abstraction and iconic abstraction
now I will flip over to the Jupiter
notebook 2 to show you some ways that
that we could that we can do this in
code so I will just pull this over to
the other
the other screen here okay so to
calculate the diffs that I was showing
you earlier I can simply use some code
to read in those images the state 10 and
state 11 and I can show those and the
exciting thing about Jupiter notebook is
that it is a it's a repple so I can I
can see the results the images in line
right there when I execute the code and
I can work I can work iteratively so
it's maybe not quite as easy as the
tracing paper but it still enables this
this rapid feedback loop of
experimentation and now to say to
calculate the DIF I need not just shades
of grey but I need discrete values to
represent where Picasso made those marks
on the limestone for his lithography so
I can calculate the mask and now these
are the masks for four-state 10 and 11
and it's a little bit noisy but that's
okay this is rapid experimentation
it's prototyping and now to calculate
the DIF I can simply use boolean boolean
logic set logic where I can say that the
unchanged portion of the image is
wherever wherever there is a pixel that
is present in both a and B the deleted
portions are the pixels that are present
in a and not B the the tilde character
being an operator bitwise operator to to
invert there so again unchanged a and B
deleted as a and not B and then the
opposite added portions are not a and B
and now if I show the unchanged portion
we see again it's noisy but we see this
curve of the back we see the legs if I
show the deleted portion there you're
seeing mostly those interior lines like
we
walk through Picasso removing and
showing the added portions these are
again with some noise the the new lines
from that eleventh and final state and
now if I want to color code it I can
simply define my colors white red green
and black here then I will make an empty
image here of white which there's not as
expected there's not a lot to look at
here it's just an empty white image now
if I add if I add red to the image I'm
simply saying okay use this as a mask
and whatever portions of the image
should be deleted set those equal to my
red color and now if I show it I've
added that layer as if I was working in
Photoshop but I'm doing it in code and
now I have the red portion here color
coded now I can add the green and now
I'm it's starting to come together I'm
seeing these new lines and finally if I
add the black lines for where there was
no difference where there was not a
change between states then I have this
final image here and if I repeat this
process I can do this for all the
transitions between between states
imitating what I did in the very
beginning with my tracing paper but
using the advantage of the computational
medium to to save me some work
especially on some of those earlier
states where there's just a lot more
there it's more complex right now if I
can bring this this line simplification
notebook over
now if I use just a few lines of code
for the Douglas puker algorithm then I'm
actually able to use another feature of
the Jupiter notebook called interactive
widgets where I've defined this function
called simplify that applies the Douglas
puker algorithm and it takes two
parameters the image that you want to
simplify and then a parameter called
tolerance that says how much do you want
to simplify it by and if I drag this
slider you can see that when I start to
increase the tolerance it's it's keeping
the same fundamental shape but simply
mning it out in a way making it more
angular really and if I continue to
extend that then it gets more and more
boxy and in my opinion kind of kind of
interesting here let's see if I can
extend that so now here's in between and
these are these are really higher values
than would normally be intended for the
line simplification because we've lost
the original shape the original line but
that's kind of the point for our
artistic purpose here and so if I take
it all the way to the maximum value that
I'd set for the maximum possible value
of 150 then it gets to this to this line
here this simplified contour which in
some ways is getting closer moving state
ten to something that gets closer to
resembling state eleven because a lot of
the complexity in the back was removed
we see some simplification of the head
and horn although obviously it is a
different more angular shape and so this
was a way to use math and code and
iterate and explore in the repple to to
simplify that bowl but in a way that was
more pure abstraction and does not fully
or Picasso's process again it's it's not
perfect but even the mistakes are
interesting so I think about Picasso's
famous quote about about computers and
of course he was he was speaking at a
time when computers were big impersonal
machines used to calculate missile
trajectories for war and sadly that
often is still what computers are used
for today but they can also be used for
for more right and they can raise
interesting questions they don't just
give answers they do give questions like
how do I try to capture this unique
flavor of abstraction that splits the
difference between picture plane and
iconic abstraction I'm not sure yet how
to do that but by exploring in the
medium of computation it's enabled me to
to imagine some possibilities and to
have an interesting journey along the
way getting new insights into how
Picasso created his bowls so at the
beginning we said part of the motivating
reason for this talk is the is that
Picasso felt stuck even like we
sometimes feel stuck whether you're
working in art or in software or
mathematics oftentimes he makes it look
so easy
great artists and geniuses they make it
look so easy but even Picasso got stuck
and so if you feel stuck if you feel
creatively blocked you can think about
the process that Picasso used when he
was able to save his variations to
explore where he was going and work
backwards don't feel like you have to
jump all the way to the simplified
version but paradoxically you may have
to start with a more complex version and
then pare away at it in order to get
through your creative block to achieve
the simplified vision that you had in
mind all along thank you
you